well it is a day no one will ever forget
queen elizabeth the second the world's
longest reigning monarch has died now
many people here in las vegas shared
their shock shared their sadness
including one person who was across the
pond when she heard the news sasha
loftus joins us now in studio tonight
with more on her story sasha denise and
brian i spoke with a woman from here in
las vegas who's visiting london tonight
as our local british community gathered
to pay their respects as well while
their reactions to this day is different
they know it's one they'll never forget
i have never i have nothing to compare
this to it's a monumental moment in
history no one will ever forget
queen elizabeth ii dead at 96 years old
after the longest reign in british
history i couldn't believe it happened
while i'm here angenine simonson lives
here in las vegas but was in london when
the news broke and describes an entire
country's shock and sadness as she went
to buckingham palace to pay her respects
they started you know tearing up and
sniffles and tears and then
their phones started ringing
back here at home dozens including
england native brett sullivan gathered
to honor the queen from afar at the
crown and anchor pub it's a very very
sad day and i've been talking to friends
all around the world as a member of the
military he served with prince harry the
duke of sussex and has met now king
charles iii
but calls the queen an irreplaceable
symbol you're just a great ambassador
for our country and
and she will be sorely missed as she's
both mourned and remembered in the
united kingdom
[Music]
and all around the world i'm not british
but
it's still the queen the queen still
died
simonson said the national anthem was
playing on the radio when the news broke
in london but the lyrics quickly changed
from god save the queen to god save the
king to honor king charles iii ascension
to the throne denise well sasha of
course a lot of tributes being seen all
across the valley tonight including this
special video here playing on the top of
every hour at the canopy at fremont
street experience fremont officials say
they are going to keep playing this all
the way through saturday night and the
high roller was lit up in purple tonight
for a couple of hours you can just
barely see it honoring the queen's
memory and one other thing to show you
as far as tributes go resorts world on
the north end paying tribute to her
despite the little bit of the dust you
can kind of see it here leaving a
special graphic on the huge led screen